je vais tout de suite donné la parole à
monsieur chambrette pour donc nous
évoquer les priorités pour le retour de
la france au plan européen donc bonjour
à tous rappelle dominique chambrette
subissent président des producteurs de
blé mais aussi céréaliers en bourgogne
et c'est très intéressant ce qui était
dit tout à l'heure par rapport à
l'entreprise agricole ou ce mon
entreprise fait peur à tout le monde moi
je sais une entreprise agricole que j'ai
créé que mes fils mais on peut
effectivement avoir une société qui soit
aussi familial et qui permettent dans
mes trois fils sont installés et on est
salarié qui permet aussi de créer de
l'économie sur le milieu rural parfois
dans des grands comptes c'est la seule
économie
moi j'ai le privilège d'être né en 1970
que je connais si vous venez tout ce qui
était réclamé par les uns et les autres
par rapport à des réglementations la
dérégulation
cette politique à l'école on ne l'avait
pas dire nous les salles les saints
alliés on avait une organisation de
marché qui fonctionnait d'ailleurs les
principes fondateurs de 2,2 de la pac en
60 c'était l'unicité des prix or j'ai
remarqué qu'on avait beaucoup parlé de
distorsion de complot mais c'étaient des
prix à l'intérieur la solidarité
financière entre les états dire tous les
états
à bombay le budget de la pac par rapport
à la richesse du pays on en viendra aux
budgets et puis la préférence
communautaire
donc tout ce qui a servi de base à la
création de cette politique agricole
alors moi je suis pro européen ch je
considère que la politique agricole
c'est une belle machine qui a bien
fonctionné et si elle a dérapé c'est
pour des tas de raisons ou prolong l'éco
responsabilité de beaucoup d'états ont
aussi réussi à l'affaiblir et par
rapport à ici aux républicains je crois
que l'objectif c'est de gagner la
présidentielle en 2017 pour sauver
l'économie du pays mais aussi de
l'agriculteur et on doit ramener au
bercail certain nombre de nos collègues
qui on l'a vu dans les régionales se
sont sentis tentés par un vote extrêmes
anti européens en petit politique
agricole entier rosstat c'est à dire
comment re positive et la politique
agricole maintenant et dans cette
prévision comme vous l'avez dit de 2002
2022 mais pour revenir à ce qu était la
politique quelques heures on avait une
politique qui était quand même
extraordinaire avec des prix garantis
avec du stockage vont parler en parler
notre collègue stéphane parlait de cette
campagne céréalière difficile mais
l'intervention s'est glissée c'est à
dire on avait une machine extraordinaire
le marché descendait la collectivité
c'est à dire l'état voire en créer
l'onic allemand la france était en
avance sur l'europe
il ya eu une époque où la france était
en avance sur l'europe en 1936 bon vous
voyez que puisque c'est la création de
l'organisation de marchés en 1936 elle
est quand même parti de la france et
après c'est l'europe qui s'en vient donc
là on est inversé un petit peu les
tendances
donc voilà on retirait de la
marchandisation le marché ça crée de
nouveau la rareté et les prix remonter
c'était une belle machine tout ça
c'était du privé au bout alors d'abord
avec la réforme de 92 où on a abaissé
les prix au cours mondial
et puis à donner des aides aux
agriculteurs bon ça bce d'abaisser des
prix d'ailleurs s'était dit le fait que
les céréales soit été abaissé sa part
régler si j'ai bien compris les crises
de lil wayne
au temps de crise de l'élevage en cause
mais ce qu'il faut aussi dire pour nous
céréaliers et j'ai été très attentif à
ce que dit le président des producteurs
de porcs chaque fois qu'une porcherie
ferme c'est une usine de transformation
de blé qui ferme à dire quand on parle
de 2,2 de fermetures d'entreprises tout
l'élevage et la première transformation
donc sur le territoire un délocalisât
donc toutes les productions sont sont
liées entre elles donc ces politiques et
d'écoles qui s'est mis en route a bien
fonctionné on est passé quand même de
6,9 à 28 c'est un peu plus difficile
l'intégration de pays qui ont un système
social différent a fait que l'évolution
était telle que la tendance à la
renationalisation renationalisation de
la politique agricole mais
renationalisation de la politique
environ environnementale c'est important
parce que c'est les deux contraintes qui
pèsent sur la compétitivité de
l'agriculture française et sur les
distorsions de concurrence que l'on peut
avoir avec nos voisins
alors on a beaucoup parlé de distorsion
de concurrence sociale pour le port avec
notamment le coût du travail etc nous
laisser aller la distorsion de
concurrence
elle est aussi sur le système dette par
exemple les allemands ont choisi un
système uniformisé dans les länder les
différents de la france ce qui fait que
moi qui suis par exemple céréaliers
bourguignon donc dans une production
plus tôt la production de deux de blé
plus au sud en france sur des marchés
européens je sus de ceux des marchés
méditerranéens pardon et européens du
sud par exemple on s'est fait prendre la
moitié de marché italien par nos amis
allemands hongrois roumains qui eux
parce qu'ils ont 100 euros l'hectare de
nous ont la capacité de vendre du blé 15
euros moins ça a été rappelé on vend
aussi en dessous de nos coûts de
production à dire les coûts de
production ses 180 190 euros
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il doit être
moins de 130 euros des parfums dont
prague en est loin mais bon ça fait
partie de l'économie de marché
je remets pas en cause aujourd'hui mais
des politiques les renationalisation de
pâques fait que chaque pays repositionne
une politique et on s'éloigne de la
politique agricole et on dit que c'est
la faute de l'europe
alors c'est pas la faute de l'europe
c'est pas la faute de l'europe
si en france on a choisi a évidemment la
dernière réforme le foll où on
comprendre et choisir arbitrairement un
exemple que la la ferme france s étaient
52 et voilà alors 52 hectares si vous
êtes sur les coteaux du morvan où 52 ha
si vous êtes dans les prairies de
normandie 52 ha si vous êtes en bon
enfin ça veut rien dire si a vu un pays
où la moyenne ne veut rien dire
c'est bien ça tough on crée une
distorsion de concurrence non seulement
entre les producteurs français
mais avec nos collègues européens et
après on dit que c'est la faute de
l'europe
la deuxième chose armes autoroute moi
j'ai passé là c'est intéressant ce
qu'elle a dit ça serait bien qu'elle
dise que moi je trouve que
l'environnement c'est une valeur de
gauche mais le développement durable
c'est une valeur de droite et on doit le
revendiquer ici au rugby parce que on
est responsable on est responsable on
des responsables de la terre de qu'on a
hérité ou qu'on a acheté peu importe
mais qui viennent nos parents de nos
grands-parents ou des de nos voisins et
on veut la transmettre à nos enfants ou
alors aux enfants de nos voisins donc on
a la responsabilité que ses pairs là
dans 50 ans elle doit nourrir les
français élisent ont donc c'est notre
responsabilité tu es membre et j'ai
jamais vu des gens aient envie
d'installer leurs enfants leurs
petits-enfants saloper leur leur outil
de travail
on est d'accord d'accord donc appuyé ici
aux républicains l'obtention de
développement durable alors comme la
première table ronde excusez moi après
un retard phénoménal et rené chargé de
récupérer le retard pour leur confiance
j'ai encore dix arrivées et intervenir à
leur juste une seconde sur ce qui se
passe en 2017 2017
faut faire attention parce que il ya la
fragilité du budget ce qu'il fait une
politique agricole 6 d'abord un budget
et on voit ici là notamment en allemagne
des gens qui disent attendait il ya des
crises plus graves et l'agriculture d'un
immigrant faut régler et on bat pourquoi
pas par exemple les agriculteurs sont
pas contents du paiement vers et bien on
supprime le paiement vers ce serait une
erreur stratégique parce que c'est le
moyen de valoriser ce qu'on a toujours
fait justement dans une logique de
développement durable
donc il faut pas que quelque chose qui
nous est fort monique parcours remettra
en cause et livre on demande la pac que
j'ai cité le budget de la pac et que
l'on n'ait encore vers une
renationalisation et en 2000
l'évolution de cet acte c'est bien aussi
pour le problème assurantiel c'est à
dire on a parlé des crises on a plus de
petites gestion des crises mais on a on
est en train de mettre en place alors
s'arrêter
ça a commencé de manière timide mais ça
va se mettre en place
vers un système climatique d'assurance
climatique mais la vraie réflexion pour
2020 alors qui peut commencer en 2017
c'est effectivement comment on va
sécuriser les chiffres d'affaires
comment on peut avoir une politique qui
effectivement permettre de gommer la
fluctuation
je vous en reparlerai rapidement en
conclusion de cette table ronde à la vue
de son match